but first America and shutdown day 15
now today we lost more than 800
Americans who had tested positive for
the corona virus that's the largest
single-day number since this nightmare
began a stunning three-quarters of our
fellow citizens are living under some
sort of stay at home order issued by
state governors New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo while noting that they're not at
the kovat apex yet it did offer some
encouraging news with testing more
people than any state in the country and
I'm very proud of that more per capita
than China and South Korea number of
intubations was down not much but it was
down and that's a good sign
you also see the number of discharges
going up and that's consistent numbers
in Washington State and even California
are also offering some hope slide that
gives us great hope and understanding
about what is possible on the bottom of
the slide where you can barely see that
blue line at the very bottom that's the
current cases in California the
cumulative cases in California where
they're doing significant testing the
next line up is Connecticut the orange
line is New Jersey the blue line is New
York the yellow line is Washington well
that's encouraging graphs in the states
where you see those improvements but
tomorrow is only April first and many of
you want more answers now given the
massive disruptions to life the huge
financial toll the loss of our basic
liberties Americans dying more are
asking why the models for tracking the
disease in some cases have been so far
off now the folks at 5:38 have a theory
there's also the issue there right of
uncollected or inaccurate data to
determine the fatality rate you have to
divide the number of people who have
died from the disease by the number of
people in fact
the disease in this case we really don't
have a reliable account for the number
of people infected so to put it
mathematically we don't know the
denominator now we already know that
some of the early data from the Imperial
College which the US and the UK was
using to model its early numbers was off
by many factors but of course most
Americans they don't have the time to
dig into the underlying data so of
course they rely on good faith on the
experts dr. Anthony Fauci talked a lot
today about their various models the
models they rely on to inform the
mitigation strategies that's what the
model tells you what's going to do what
we do is that every time we get more
data you feed it back in and relook at
the model is the model really telling
you what's actually going on models are
as good as the assumptions you put into
them even though it says according to
the model which is a good model that
we're dealing with this is full
mitigation as we get more data as the
week's go by that could be modified that
could be modified one way or another
and indeed the mortality rate
projections already have been modified
now the death rate from koba 19 is
likely around point six six percent if
counting a mild or asymptomatic cases
according to a new study now past
estimates had placed the mortality rate
somewhere between 2% and an unbelievable
3.4 percent which would be devastating
then another study and the journal
Nature Medicine brought it down by
almost half to around 1.4 percent
mortality but in this new study
researchers dug deep into the data to
determine the true infection fatality
ratio that is the mortality rate that
includes the people with mild cases and
sometimes not symptomatic at all who may
have not been counted before it's really
interesting now the death rate vary
greatly by age 0 to 9 year olds point
zero zero one six percent but age 80 and
above it was 7.8 percent and other
age groups are in there as well a
renowned mathematician quoted in the
study noted that the infection fatality
ratio is a very important piece of data
that will help to guide the response
from various government and public
health authorities worldwide again what
we're saying on the Ingraham angle is
the data matters it matters to all of us
real facts real science
we shouldn't be referring to old data
that has already been disproven because
that only ends up scaring people and
then confusing a lot of people who
actually deserve transparency and a full
accounting now also my message to Pelosi
and company with her little nasty asides
over the weekend that got a huge
reaction last night so it bears
repeating tonight we all hear a lot
about a whole-of-government approach
almost every day we hear
whole-of-government so i'm a question
why is Congress out of session do you
know that Congress stayed in session
during the Spanish flu and also during
World War two after all we're told that
this battle against kovat is a war and
the government's response to it has
resulted in millions and millions of
Americans losing their jobs and their
dreams in an attempt to try to bring
down that curve tens of thousands of
Americans could die tragically still
from Kovan we all want to save more
lives we want to do everything we can
but we also at the same time and it's a
it's a heavy lift it's a lot of
balancing here we have to give Americans
a realistic sense of achievable metrics
to measure success in the end so all the
graphs they're informative and they're
nice to see but we have to know that
parents are asking tonight what numbers
will it take so their kids can go back
to school at some point maybe maybe next
month a month after maybe in the fall
what numbers will it take and what
numbers will it take for Americans to
return to church it's really important
for a lot of Americans to be able to go
to church every week what about travel
what numbers will it take for us to be
able to travel even to another state to
see a relative what about going back to
work that's assuming the job
that someone had last month will even be
there next month the month after or
sometime in June asking these questions
safeguarding our health and welfare and
our liberties is what all three branches
of government this is what our founders
understood the brilliance of our
founders they understood that you needed
all three branches working together and
they should be right now checks and
balances of course we all love and value
the doctors and all the health care
professionals that are just heroes
tonight but we also love our freedom and
our ability to support our families so
how likely is it that on April 25th we
might hear that all we really need to
shut down through the early part of June
in order to bend the curve even more we
better get ready for that message
earlier not later we should discuss
those metrics now not in three weeks the
mitigation steps that are on your 30 day
plan is that enough we hope it's enough
we hope it's enough we hope we're at a
level where we could say let's go
because our country wants to get back to
work I could ask the doctors to answer
that question again back to the level to
the numbers now speaking of doctors this
is what sanjay gupta said today what
we've been seeing in terms of the way
that this information these
recommendations have been sort of rolled
out is that they're coming out somewhat
piecemeal right at first it was a couple
of weeks and now it's been extended
another month I had a chance to speak to
doctor about you today interviewed him
for our podcast and I sort of asked him
that question I said is this is this
part of the strategy to to to slowly you
know ease the country into to these
these existing and in deepening or at
least lengthening guidelines and he sort
of said well yeah look we don't we don't
want to shock people with this we want
to look at the data but the data
certainly is suggesting that wolf this
was likely to go on beyond April 30th
okay you hear that beyond April 30th
you've heard of mission creep we may be
looking at shutdown creep shutting down
the country until mid summer that's you
know that's what we're all hearing here
would invariably prevent a lot of kovat
19 deaths that would be a great thing so
much shutting down for the entire year
but Americans like the doctors they need
to know what objective success looks
like and whether it's even achievable
within any reasonable timeframe and at
what costs to our family's future and to
your basic civil liberties that said
despite the media's best efforts today
the president knows that there are
promising therapies already being used
right now I've watched the poorest
woman's really gloomy data on these
trials nothing that I've heard I mean
that's the first question I make every
morning if the good news is we haven't
heard anything bad in other words
there's no catastrophic events I want to
give people hope too
you know I'm a cheerleader for the
country so it's easy to be negative and
then everybody could be negative but I'm
a cheerleader for our country
and I want them to do a great job so the
number can be kept and I've always said
it I want as few a number of people to
die as possible and that's all we're
working on and he also said America
wants to get back meaning get back to
work Trump is doing exactly what he
should be doing he's consulting with the
scientists listening to all the
stakeholders including the American
citizens and he's confidently reminding
us that no matter what the challenge you
bet
America is up for it and those are my
thoughts at the end of the shutdown day
15